when a person thinks deeply and
seriously he has a bad time among the
general
public a creation of importance can only
be produced when its author isolates
himself it is a child of
solitude the greatest evil that can
befall a man is that he should come to
think ill of himself
our friends show us what we can do our
enemies teach us what we must
do Destiny grants us our
wishes but in its own way in order to
give us something beyond our
wishes do not give in too much to
feelings
an overly sensitive heart is an unhappy
possession on this shaky
Earth of all the thieves idiots are the
most
harmful they steal our time and mood
from
us many people take no care of their
money until they come near the end of it
and others do the same with their time
if you knew how rarely we are understood
correctly you would be silent more
often he who moves not
forward goes
backward you can easily judge a man's
character by how he treats those who can
do nothing for
him
mountains cannot be surmounted except by
winding
paths if you get by achieving your goals
is not as important as what you become
by achieving your
goals if you treat an individual as he
is he will remain how he is but if you
treat him as if he were what he ought to
be and could be he will become what he
ought to be and could
be the most ridiculous desire is the
desire to please
everybody doubt can only be removed by
action too many parents make life hard
for their children by trying to
zealously to make it easy for
them Talent is formed in
silence character and stormy
disturbances of
light everything is hard before it is
easy if each of us sweeps right under
our feet the whole world will be
clean
give a man a purpose worth living for
and he can survive in any
situation to be pleased with one's
limits is a wretched
State love is an ideal thing marriage a
real
thing one always has enough time if one
applies it
well it is better to make an
approximately correct decision than a
precise
mistake what is not started
today is never finished
tomorrow catch a good mood it so rarely
visits
us everybody wants to be
somebody but nobody wants to
grow there are people who never make
mistakes because they don't want to do
it nothing is worth more than this
day nothing shows a man's character more
than what he laughs
at no one knows what his powers are
until he uses
them the way you see people is the way
you treat them and the way you treat
them is what they
become true greatness begins with
understanding your own
insignificance there is more to hopeless
slavery than the slavery of those slaves
who consider themselves free from
Fetters an intelligent person is not the
one who knows a lot but the one who
knows
himself the best government is that
which teaches us to govern
ourselves we know accurately only when
we know little with knowledge doubt
increases man's manners are a mirror in
which his portrait is
reflected whoever wishes to keep a
secret must hide the fact that he
possesses
one in gratitude is a kind of
weakness outstanding people are never
ungrateful
everyone hears only what he
understands go to foreign countries and
you will get to know the good things one
possesses at
home divide and conquer is a wise rule
but unite and Lead is even
better knowing is not enough we must
apply willing is not enough we must
do for a man to achieve all that is
demanded of him he must regard himself
as greater than he
is those who stopped loving and making
mistakes have buried themselves
alive
a person lives a real life if he is
happy with someone else's
happiness as soon as you trust
yourself you will know how to
live the greatest thing in this world is
not so much where we
stand as in what direction we are
moving
art is the mediator of what cannot be
said we all live upon the past and
through the past we are
destroyed correction does much but
encouragement does
more the longer you live alone the less
the crowd Appeals
the less you need others to fill the
silence the more you find peace in
solitude's
Whispers I can tell you honest friend
what to
believe believe life it teaches better
than a book or
orator